for Bangladeshis flooding is a way of
life with its mix of monsoons and
cyclones 1/4 of the country is under
water at some time of the year their
lives are very much shaped by these
forces and when you travel to the
southwest of Bangladesh you see one way
that they've tried to deal with that
which is holders that are designed to
hold back the water but what they're
learning is that trying to hold back the
water comes with a price
[Music]
my name is Warren Cornwall I'm a
contributing correspondent for science
magazine this reporting was supported
partly by funding from the Pulitzer
Center on Crisis Reporting polder is a
Dutch word they used it to reclaim a lot
of land for farmland but the river
systems there aren't nearly as dynamic
as they are in Bangladesh so you know a
number of people in Bangladesh said you
take Dutch solutions and you apply them
to Bangladeshi problems and you can wind
up with some unexpected consequences
well Bangladesh should be built this
infrastructure you know half a century
ago to protect themselves from flooding
almost the entire southwest coastal
region ringed by embankments Boulder is
a really big island holder 32 for
example is about 80 square kilometers
and more than 30,000 people live there
because polders impede the natural
movement of water and sediment the
rivers are filling with silt lands
inside the polders are being starved of
new soil that would otherwise flow in
and now these lands are sinking that
means when a polder is flooded the areas
inside the walls turn into bathtubs
that's what happened to Poulter 32 in
2009 a wave of water originating from
cyclone ila combined with strong
currents burst through the polar it was
one of several polders damaged during
the cyclone which is blamed for a
hundred and fifty deaths and two hundred
and seventy million dollars in damages
in Bangladesh studying the aftermath
researchers found that land just outside
Poulter 32 was ten centimeters above the
typical high tide which suggests that
the land would only be swamped by the
highest tides and inside the polder
researchers found the influx of water
brought silt more than a third of a
meter on average
so a team of researchers concluded that
rather than relying on taller walls they
should think about introducing
controlled flooding to raise the land
this approach is not without precedent
in Bangladesh a region 30 kilometres
inland tried to harness natural forces
and use controlled flooding starting in
the 1990s inland folders are designed to
protect against flooding by sea water
driven far up river channels during high
tide but these rivers with smaller
slower currents started clogging with
silt when they were trapped between
polders farms and towns inside some of
the polders have become waterlogged
stewing in stagnant water for months
desperate farmers finally decided to cut
gaps in the walls to let the water in
and that had this interesting effect
where suddenly you had the rivers being
able to flow back into the land brought
the extra sediment into the land so the
land started to get built back up after
years of being starved of sediment and
then the rivers also became unblocked
because the sediment had somewhere to go
besides the river beds this initial
success led the government to develop a
controlled flooding program for inland
polders a decade ago the latest program
is on the Cova dock river their workers
dug a canal connecting the river to a
wetland called a beal inside the polder
visit today and the effects are evident
half a meter of fresh land has been
gained in some parts of the bill the
river runs deep and fast water is once
again draining from the nearby boulders
enabling farmers to resume planting and
cultivating fields that had been
waterlogged the endangered Ganges River
Dolphin returned with the rivers flow
but it's not all good news the bill
won't be returned to cultivation for
another two years when the canal will be
closed back up alright talk to a number
of landowners who complained that either
they hadn't been fully compensated for
the land that was now under water and
then that doesn't really do anything for
the landless labourers who work on farms
but they don't own any of the farmland
the way the system is currently run
they're not compensated at all families
have lost their homes and livelihoods
some were relocated while others ended
up living
embankments and the land inside the
Polar's hasn't risen evenly with the
area near the canal benefiting the most
engineers still have a ways to go to
decipher sediment dynamics and consider
how best to direct flooding the greatest
challenge is convincing the people that
controlled flooding will eventually pay
off researchers found that government
agencies were disconnected from locals
spawning distrust and anger that has
derailed the expansion of controlled
flooding measures meanwhile sea level is
projected to rise 0.4 to 1.5 meters on
the coast by 2100 putting Bangladesh at
even greater risk in the future back
downstream in places like Poulter 32
there are currently no plans to
implement controlled flooding instead
they're rebuilding the walls this is
basically like hitting the refresh
button rebuilding these polders to
withstand what's expected in 2050 as
long as the polder walls keep the storm
surges at bay in some sense you know
these folks are okay right but it's when
something breaks that you appreciate how
vulnerable they are and how the polders
have actually made them more vulnerable
[Music]
[Music]
you